not to piss off the positive Poes in the
room but if you haven't gotten what you
want then you're not worthy of it period
and that's okay now you can admit that
you suck and improve better to know
you're bad for a season than pretend
you're good for a lifetime you're not
making as much money as you want because
you're not as good as you think you are
you're not struggling from imposter
syndrome you're a student and pretending
to be a teacher no students say they
feel like frauds for trying to learn
you're a fraud when you get up to teach
the class and you've never done
it
deep I think it's just giving yourself
permission to suck it's giving yourself
permission to be unhappy it's giving
yourself permission to not achieve while
you do for a long period of time it's
giving yourself permission to lose
friends it's giving yourself permission
to do things that's different than
people in your Social Circle or your age
group are doing it's giving giving you
permission giving yourself
permission to be an exception so that
you can become exceptional and a lot of
that the whole positive poly Mantra of
like the I saw that I saw a post a girl
made and she was like you are worthy and
that's what made that tweet all my
tweets are just responses to [__] I say
and so this girl was like you like I say
this to myself in the morning like you
are worthy you are amazing you are a
goddess and I was like you're not a
goddess cuz you don't control me um and
you don't have the things that you want
you keep thinking that you saying that
you're worthy is going to somehow make
it true but like the way that you know
you're worthy is that you have
it that's it like that is the litus test
are you worthy of a billion dollars well
are you a billionaire no then you're not
worthy and so just like I think we have
these things it's just like uh you're
unbalanced it's like you're not worthy
there's these things that we're program
to say oh that's bad you have to tell
everyone they're worthy you're
everyone's beautiful no if everyone were
beautiful then no one's beautiful and
yet again we're back at square one and
so it's it's I guess drinking the tonic
it's
it's going through the [__] which is
honestly the boring stuff that no one
wants to do for an extended period of
time and
uh accepting that you
suck and that it is okay because the
first step is accepting that you stuck
you suck so that you can do the Second
Step which is doing something about it
what about you're not making as much
money as you want because you're not as
good as you think you are
that's I mean I'm obviously in the
business space and that follows up with
the other one with the impostor syndrome
like people are like man um how do you
not suffer from imposter syndrome I was
like because I've done what I said I've
done and the people who get up on stage
and try and teach a class on [__] they
haven't done it's like that like you
feel like an impostor when you're an
impostor like don't try and kill that
voice listen to that voice and get the
evidence to make that voice shut the
[__] up like if like if I get on stage
and I say I can bench
315 is there like do I feel like an
imposter when I say that no I stay fact
but presumably if you're if you're
pioneering and breaking new ground you
know you're you just put the biggest
investment that you ever did into this
new thing that is a new level that you
get to and that's one that's to do with
Finance but could be another one that's
to do with capacity or competence you
could be sitting down in a room doing a
deal which is time Bound in a way that
it's never been before or is in an
industry only tangential to one that
you've been in before each time that you
do something new by definition you're an
impostor because you haven't done it
before now if you're teaching that's
different but if you're entering if
you're growing sufficiently quickly most
of the time it's fresh snow so I like
this is a f a topic I love but I think
the difference between doing something
new and being an impostor is one is
pretending to be something that they're
not so like I made the biggest
investment school I'm making a bet that
I think communities are going to be huge
and I think that there's a ton of people
who want to you know teach skills they
have in communities Etc and school.com
can help but
like it would only be an impostor if I
said this is like I guarantee it no
matter what this is going to be the
biggest thing ever and one of the big
things that I repeat and from the
marketing I say it all the time I say
State the facts and tell the
truth like the best Marketing in the
entire world is truth now if the truth
isn't compelling it doesn't mean you lie
it means you change the world to make
the facts
compelling as in if I say man I want to
be like I you see this one all the time
uh 18-year-olds who are like I want to
be a motivational speaker right you say
okay well what are your facts you've
done nothing great so they then lie so
that they can try and claim success that
they don't deserve so they can get
Authority that they can't back up and
eventually are called out and are flat
and to be fair they only impress people
who don't know anything
anyways so if they're honest about it
they look at their fact sheet and say
what would what would a motivational
speaker have to have in order for them
to have
authority and then that becomes your
action list of what you need to do and
then once those facts are the truth then
you can State the facts and tell the
truth and then people will be like wow
that's so motivational but all you did
was tell the truth and so like that is
why I've so wholeheartedly rejected one
like you are worthy you are not worthy
if you had it then you wouldn't even
need to say you were worthy because
you'd already [__] have it and if you
were in like I struggle with impostor
syndrome why you only struggle imposter
SYM because you're [__] lying like
that's why you feel like an imposter and
now they're like well I didn't the thing
is is you can fudge the truth like you
can you cannot lie is very different
than telling the truth like I can make
something seem a certain way without
deliberately breaking the law but I'll
know and that's why you feel like an
imposter because you [__] know and
there's the guy in the other room who's
clearing his thr be like that's not
[__] true and then that Discord but
if you just say what you have done or
you say what you are doing I'm making
this big investment it's a big bet for
me the reason I'm making this bet is
because I see this trend and I think
it's a good idea I could be [__]
wrong but I'm not going to feel like an
impostor because of it because that's
the
truth thinking about the community thing
I had a conversation a little while ago
I don't I don't think that you're that
you're far off wrong especially in an
age of automation this guy made a really
great point which you probably thought
of which is one of the very few things
that you can't automate is
community can't AI community no what
you're GNA have I mean mayil bots in
yeah exactly one guy one guy and a
thousand Bots that are all doing it
maybe GPT 10 can do that or whatever but
the next
this inter quartile period whatever
we're coming up to yeah is the easiest
way to to hedge against automation I
think is to focus on community in other
news this episode is brought to you by
nomatic you might have seen that I
recently was on the road for a full 28
days using just hand luggage because
hold luggage is a scop meant to keep you
poor and late and almost everything is
down to this backpack and the carry-on
that I was using this is their travel
pack their 20 L travel pack and honestly
it is the best backpack that I've ever
found it would take way longer than I've
got to explain all of the different
pieces of tech that are inside of this
but it basically allows you to pack so
much more stuff with so much less fuss
and it's outstanding the're beautifully
designed not over engineered and has a
lifetime guarantee so this is literally
the final backpack that you you will
ever need to buy also you can return or
exchange your bag for any reason within
30 days so you can buy it try it use it
and carry stuff in it for a full month
and if you don't like it they'll give
you your money back head to the link in
the show notes below or go to nomatic
docomo wisdom use the code modern wisdom
at checkout for a 20% discount off
everything sitewide that's Nom matic.com
wisdom and modern wisdom a
checkout thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that clip with our the
ful length 3 and 1/ half hour podcast is
right here waiting for you go on tap it